[Music]
hello and welcome back to the endgame
class my name is Caleb bindi and today
I'm going to be taking you through some
end games some famous semi made up
between knights and bishops we're going
to see the classic night versus Bishop
kind of endgame see when it's good for
the night when it's good for the bishop
and what you really need to do in order
to win these positions so first up here
is a position that I just invented this
isn't from a real game but this is a
classic case of a bishop against a
knight so first off of course who is
better in this endgame the question we
must always ask ourselves obviously it
looks as though this Knight is better
than this bishop but white does have the
benefit of having more G pawns than his
opponent white with the extra G pawn is
just up upon so I wanted to ask you guys
at home who is better who is better what
do you guys think starting off with the
questions early for you tonight who is
better white or black a cool vector says
White's unite is meaningless I have more
pawns fair enough
black closed positions white Justin's
seen this before I think I have gone
over this one in an in-person lecture
but it has not made it to the Internet
I wanted to introduce it because I felt
like this lecture was good enough to go
online looks like a draw says mani white
white white everybody wants to be white
here so how do you go about evaluating a
position like this it's not so easy to
figure out one method is to just look at
the position statically like this say
okay white as the pawn black has a
better night you know who do I want to
be I don't have more pawns you know you
can do that that's not a very good way
of evaluating the position looks like a
draw is another thing you can say you
know maybe the knight balances out the
pawn but the way to think about this is
to once again come up with plans for
both sides come up with winning plans
that you can try and enact so for white
what does winning this game look like if
you claim white is better then you have
to come up with some way for white to
win this game so those of you in the
chat
who said white is better now you know
people are switching to say chat is to
say black but if you did say white was
better if you want to make that claim
and then you absolutely have to come up
with some plan for trying to win this
game
so ask you guys at home what you come up
with for white to try to win if black
does nothing in fact I'll go as far as
to say for the next 5 moves I'll play
King G at King h7 King G a king h7 so
let's see if you can come up with a
winning plan against black doing
absolutely nothing that's kind of the
first way you can figure it out
a cool vector can't come up with a plan
can't come up with a plan there is
actually a plan here for white to very
much greatly improve his position that
black is gonna have to look out for he's
not careful
I want my bishop on e one okay so
granted wish granted what's the next
step went over the bishop to g1 okay now
that that is a feat and I don't know if
you can really pull off here kicking off
one I'll even give you this I'll even
give you this
what's your winning plan King F 1 e 2 F
3
okay what's your winning plan
what's your winning plan I'm giving you
guys a lot here walk the King all the
way to the e6 pawn and that is something
I will not give you if you start running
to this Queen site you have to be ready
to meet my king over there all right
you're not you're not getting in over
there can't can't give you that much
so they're chunk Jake heat I think has
already said it before and Jim now has
the answer as well as little Matthew
Tomlinson the move G for is a playable
move for white and this may not even be
a winning plant if black just ignores it
you can play the move from g5 but you
have to be a little bit cautious I can
even just kind of come out here and it's
not so easy to win this game even still
but this move g4 g5 definitely vastly
improves White's position if white gets
this then black is always going to have
to be tied down to kind of defending
this pawn so that's one thing to
definitely have to look out for in this
position so now let's flip the table a
little bit as black crazy right how do
you win this game right I think most of
the chat now agrees that black is a bit
better because even if we give white all
the time in the world all the time to
play g4 and even g5 I still don't think
it's gonna be winning there so as black
what do you want to do to try to win
this game also thank you to Pamela for
the $2 thank you very much we're kind
how can you win this position with black
just for example let's say Bishop C one
was white smooth so it is black to move
now
King to be for okay
King to g4 okay
I'm with it I'm with it
come with the King to d3r we're getting
more and more ambitious with the king
moves here King age 6 H 5 g 4 okay
alright these are ideas these are ideas
I love it I love it
Knight to c4 okay get King to g4 so
these are some pretty good ideas here so
this is how you can logically come up
with a winning plan you know in an idea
you know I'm kind of making fun with my
huge arrows but in an ideal world right
your your king is on d3 right or even
like f3 right but the question is can
you actually make that happen in in this
position that's the question you kind of
have to ask yourself here is that
something that you can make happen can
you get a king to d3 from this position
and so let's try it out what do you
think would happen so let's say king g6
king f1 just for example and then if you
continue over let's say King you to turn
you over what do you think White's gonna
do here what do you think White's gonna
do
it's trying to get all the way to be for
who has a move here for white a little
bit of bedhead going on that's not good
it's too late at night for bedhead
disaster if King you to the night takes
g3 all right you guys might be trying to
lose here Knights are worth a lot okay
so I can't take this guy cuz of this so
you could take off my pawn and I guess I
would have to come here interesting
guess that makes my life a little bit
harder right a little bit harder so
you've got me there so can we come up
with a better drawing strategy than
white because otherwise let's say Bishop
here and we proceed as you suggested if
white does nothing well then all of a
sudden you're gonna get what you wanted
right I'm gonna get what you wanted here
you're gonna get in and once you get in
are you actually winning here
the answer is is yes yes you are you can
even come here and all of a sudden it
becomes very very awkward for you in
fact this is checkmate so pretty good
stuff and of course of this motion moves
all the way you take this guy and then
this guy is going to fall before too
long as well so we have to come up with
some way that we think our opponent is
going to stop us from getting to to b4
so let's try and come up with that here
what is white gonna do let's say why it
starts with Bishop a3 for example so
what is white going to do to prevent us
from invading on the Queen side
what is white going to do to prevent
black from invading on the queenside
this is the question here of three for
white well we ran into this problem
right when you're into this problem here
where King f1 kingi - all of a sudden
you get met with the night takes g3 and
this is not so comfortable anymore
not so comfortable for white losing your
palm like this can't take because of
push so what is white going to do to
prevent us from coming to this Queen
side
Bishop b4 to e1 I don't think that quite
does it don't think that quite does it
actually I guess that that might do it
here that might do it here so let's say
Bishop before this should be one we come
over he comes over King d6 King up King
over now all of a sudden with this
Bishop on e1 perhaps White has time to
play this move King f3 and all of a
sudden your foray into the Queen side
it's not going to work so now we have to
come up with some way to prevent this
from happening with black and of course
I just scrolled a little bit too fast
and revealed the answer so of course the
idea here for black is yes in order to
win this game you need to get your king
over to the Queen side but in order to
do that you first have to make sure that
this white King isn't gonna get any
ideas any funny ideas of getting active
so what you want to do here is you want
to first place your knight on the
optimal square of g4 as a lot of people
in the chat we're saying so they we're
not answering my questions so no points
of where to do so of course the move
here if white goes for something like
this is that eventually we're going to
switch ideas and come to g4 and all of a
sudden having this Bishop on e1 doesn't
help you at all with that in mind white
can play even more what's the word even
more I don't know
white can try even harder than Bishop
before this should be one so how can
white try and still defend this position
in fact there is but one way for white
to in fact manage to draw this game
after the move King g6
or is it a trick maybe I meant to scroll
fast maybe maybe so yeah it is this move
Bishop e7 the idea being if you don't
let this night get to g4 then you don't
have to spend all your time defending
all these pumps and so things do still
get a little bit awkward for white if
this business ends up happening with
Knight takes g3 King F 294 check King g2
but this might just be enough to hold
with this White King keeping this guy
boxed out and if you try to switch
switch sides now white might just be in
time to stop you from invading so okay
definitely an interesting position here
as to why can't white or black invade on
this side of the board well exactly the
reason I just showed you you get caught
here on the f3 Square and simply no
entrance for you once you get to this
Square you do have this idea but that's
that's pretty much all you get here you
don't don't get anything else okay
so because of this funny idea of Bishop
e7 restricting the night now if we try
to come all the way over to the Queen's
side once again this Bishop defends this
Square and stops Knight f6 and so we
would run into this problem of g4 coming
on the board again this is why after
Bishop a3 there is in fact only one
winning move for black and then just to
play Knight f6 immediately went after
Bishop e7 Knight g4 and now you know big
trouble for black for white here because
both of these pawns are attacked at the
same time in no comfortable way to
defend them
so after Knight f6 if white tries to
stubbornly defend with Bishop c1 and
starts repeating of course this is now
our opportunity to bring the king all
the way over now that both of our
opponent's pieces are completely stuck
and from here it's just going to be
totally busted
for white in every conceivable endgame
so that was the introduction to the
lecture here I know we spent a while on
this but there were a lot of things
to kind of take into account here and I
wanted to walk you guys pretty slowly
kind of the thinking process you should
approach in an endgame like this first
you want to you know determine if you're
playing for a win or a draw so I asked
you first off
who's better here white or black who
should be playing for a win and we came
up with black because there's simply no
winning plan for white here there's no
way to try and generate a winning plan
so we know black is trying to win so if
we know black is trying to win we have
to come up with a winning plan for black
and you guys came up with a few ideas we
see the king trying to invade this way
and we see the king trying to invade
this way and that is how you can kind of
win positions like this you can't do it
with the night alone in almost every
case you do need an invasion for the
king so that's kind of the step we
skipped over that you guys all kind of
already understood you need to invade
with the king in order to win these
positions so in our ideal world we just
play King before and up to d3 and then
we win the game so the next step of the
thinking process is finding ways for
your opponent to try and combat this and
this was the part that went by pretty
slowly because everybody just already
wanted to play Knight of 6 to g4 cuz it
looks natural but it's important to
understand how you get there so how can
white train prevent us from getting to
b4 well we can try this by bringing his
King out in applying g4 so we had to
come up with ways to prevent this so
that's how eventually we arrived at this
best defensive try for white of bringing
this bishop to h4 and then playing King
f3 and then we realized the best way to
stop that with black is to plant the
knight on g4 immediately and then the
white pieces are tied down so that is
the thinking process I wanted to take
you guys through as we evaluate this
endgame here now sometimes you know
players can just rely on their intuition
and find the best move here like yeah
obviously I want to play Knight f6
because it you know attacks both these
pawns and it's really bad for white but
it's important to understand how you get
there for cases where this is less
obvious so the thinking process once
again determining if you're playing for
a win trying to find a winning plan and
then finding how your opponent is gonna
try to stop you and then finding out how
you can stop your opponent from trying
to stop you right that's the process you
can kind of follow
for end games like these so with that in
mind now we are equipped with our
process let's take a look at another
pretty simple one here we have kind of
the script flipped here where white is
now the one with the butter minor piece
we see a better Bishop against a rather
unfortunate Knight here so how should we
try to win this position this one's not
not too difficult not too difficult
there's a very simple phrase that most
players are lie on and end games like
these and if you know this phrase then
you probably know the winning plan
how do you find the best move for white
finding a defense seems hard or at least
non obvious well I don't have all the
answers here unfortunately you do just
have to find ways to create potential
problems for the opponent or try and
find ways that your opponent can create
potential problems for you in that
specific last case you know it kind of
makes sense that white would try to use
this extra G pawn to create problems for
the opponent because white simply didn't
have a lot else going for him in so you
naturally see okay white tries to use
the jeep on but he really can't because
of this nature for idea and then you say
well what if he tries to stop Knight g4
and then you realize why I should just
play nice you four immediately so yeah
everybody knows okay they thought of a
different phrase push them baby is
yester Center wants phrase passed pawns
must be pushed is pushed is the more
general term for it and that's exactly
the winning plan here for white you try
and push this past pawn this pawn that
cannot be stopped by another pawn and
then you force your opponent into
defending it so let's start with that
and see kind of naturally where we end
up here we see a four and let's say 95
by the opponent trying to get the knight
over to the Queen side as quickly as
possible
continue with a 5 no 97 and even a 6 is
perfectly fine to put sorry excuse me to
push now we have 96 or another perfectly
natural move here is to attack the
knight and now we see Knight a7 and so
this was kind of the obvious part of the
endgame you want to push this pawn up to
a 6 but now black has successfully
blockaded you're a pawn and I wanted to
ask you how can you try to break through
here how do you win this endgame with
white what is our winning attempt
bring the king up so that's safe to say
so if we bring the king up we're gonna
get to a blocked-off spot here on c5 so
let's say you bring the king to c5 and
light brings the king to c7 now we could
put that on the board but I want to get
you guys to the point where you can kind
of think ahead realize that that's the
position you're gonna get to and then
try and figure out what you're gonna do
from there because it's well and good to
put the Kingdon c5 in the King on c7 but
what are you hoping to achieve by doing
this what are you hoping to achieve
so there's a couple ideas going on going
around a couple ideas going around
cause trouble on the kingside seems to
be the general idea here so that is
definitely something you want to keep in
mind now it's very important that you're
careful about how you go about doing
that though because if you're not
careful then of course black is the one
with more pawns on the kingside so it's
not so easy to just push your pawns and
have nothing come of it if Black gets
his own past pawn on the Kings side I
managed to manages to trade off one or
two other pawns then all of a sudden it
could become very difficult to win with
black having his own counter play on the
Kings side so of course as always in
these minor piece end games the way to
try to win is to try to bring the King
in you need your King to be able to
invade in this case you can't just
directly take this Knight off of a 7
because black meets you on c7 but from
there you use kind of the concept of
zoogs Vong in order to force your
opponent to give you something right you
know black may be able to hold this
knight on a seven or you may be able to
stop your king from invading on the
Kings side but it's very difficult for
black to be able to do both of those
things at the same time and that's why
this endgame is winning for white so
let's go ahead and put this on the board
now because this is very natural to
include okay even king d6 is playable
here but you know eventually the king is
gonna have to come back so let's just
say we get this position right so now a
lot of ideas were actually being thrown
around here so let's say the move Knight
c8 gets played and we do actually go for
these things like g4 and g5 right if you
start playing things like this trying to
you know cause trouble on the Kings side
as it was phrased you might run into
some slight awkwardness here
for example if the move f6 is played you
do have to start being a little bit
careful about these pawns on the Kings
side example if you take here all of a
sudden G takes f6 and I'm not even
convinced that white is is winning any
more play the move g6 it also can become
a little bit more complex as well
moves like night see it can come on the
board maybe black wants to switch ideas
and go after these Kings side pawns and
the point is you just have to be a
little bit careful about what you're
doing on the Kings side
luckily for white there is a very easy
way to kind of avoid all these
complications and just kind of
immediately win the game here so see if
you can find how to put the opponent
into zoogs Vong in this position
there's a very very simple win here for
white ice a very simple I don't mean
it's it's very very easy to find but it
is a short sequence and once you do see
it it is very clearly winning for for
white
okay there's actually a lot of ideas
being tossed around here so one seems to
be Bishop d12 a four I think with the
idea of coming all the way back to e8
and see how okay this looks looks pretty
reasonable black will probably have to
play f6 85 and you might even win this a
five pawn which is good it's not the
idea that I was looking for though the
move Bishop e7 has also been suggested
but blackish is going to pass with the
move Knight a seven so I don't see the
idea there just yet
if you go to h5 first then f7 well even
the move g6 is going to be playable for
black it's not the pretty smooth but g6
then you can follow it with s6 and even
go for a move like g5 this is one of
those things they might actually be
starting to give black some hopes over
here on the Kings side of simplifying in
just a little bit not saying it works
but I'm saying you're starting to give
practical chances there should be seven
inputs black in Zook swung after night
a7 so this is kind of the idea it's
difficult to kind of communicate it with
the with the chat but Bishop c7 the
point is black of course cannot allow
this move Bishop takes see it come on
the board so here you would have to pass
with some move like 97 and the point now
for white is that black no longer has
any passing moves if this King moves
back now suddenly our King invades on
the Kings side if the King was back the
other way we can invade over here on on
the Queen side as well and as such there
is no good way for black to hold this
position white only needs to pass with
some move like g4 and maybe black can
pass as well for awhile but the fact is
white can actually just waste time with
this bishop here and at the end of the
day black is going to have to keep
making pawn moves and you're gonna run
out of pawn moves at some point here if
we keep doing this dance
eventually blacks didn't have to go for
something like e5 when you can even just
take take and bring the King over to
this King side to win the game so it was
this idea of zoogs Vonk that i wanted to
introduce to you guys Knights are
notoriously bad block haters of rook
pawns in this case the a pond and as
such white can actually just guard all
of the potential squares for this Knight
put a put the opponent into zoogs wrong
and in win this game there were other
ideas but I think this is really the
simplest way to win this endgame with
white so once again the point of this
endgame was that in order to win you
need to invade with your King and so all
of these minor piece and games are going
to be about finding ways to invade with
the
King now next I wanted to introduce a
very very famous end game that was
played between one Anatoly Karpov and
one Gary Kasparov this is an end game
from Moscow 1984 when they played and in
this position
Karpov had the white pieces and was
pressuring Garry Kasparov
in this game I don't remember all the
details surrounding this game I just
remember this end game is very very
famous so here white plays this move can
be four which is a perfectly good move
it solidifies the situation on the Queen
side making sure that black can not play
moves like a five and B 4 at a later
date just solidifying things over there
and then black played G takes h4 so I
wanted you guys to evaluate this endgame
see what you guys can come up with here
for for white in this position I will
tell you that white is going to be the
one playing for win you probably guessed
by the little one sitting next to
Anatoly Karpov name in this specific
endgame but I wanted to ask you guys how
can Karpov try to win try to come up
with a winning plan
stop pawns on h-file first G 4G 4G for
everybody wants to play the move g4
and a 5 check night takes h4i I've
caught you guys here Knight a5 check is
I'm losing plant that is a losing plant
don't forget bishops move backwards take
it for first and then think they get for
first and then think try and come up
with a winning plan from this position
try just try I want you to try g4 g4 is
right or wrong you guys tell me king
will invade if g4 very bold claims
variable clamps extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence as they
say so g4 how was your King invading I
absolutely just do not see what line you
guys are thinking of here
none of these things are winning plans
you guys are suggesting some very single
moves I want a winning plan from you
guys come on
so first and foremost hopefully you guys
can answer this question what is always
going to be the winning plan in these
end games and one form or another
of course the winning plan is going to
be invading with the king so when I ask
you to find a winning plan you should be
looking for ways to invade with the
White King and this is how you should be
determining what you should be doing
here so moves like g4 if they're with
the purpose of trying to invade with the
king then well done but unfortunately
you do need to think a little bit deeper
than that you can't just say g4 and then
the King invades because I really don't
see what you guys are talking about
okay chats movin fast now hold on let me
catch up here let me catch up here and
what you guys are saying it's tough
okay G for H takes H takes Netta v I
assume instead of F for Bishop f5 GF v
and then King up and around so put that
one on the board really quickly looks
like well first of all I guess black
passes here in this line we wanted to do
this and then come all the way around
here unfortunately
you you do get caught and you don't
quite get to totally invade here
note that black only has to guard these
two squares and other than that
the position is totally totally locked
so this King upon n game does not have
the answers you seek unfortunately so
that is not a successful way to invade
with the king so first king g2 king h3
so the point is which a lot of you guys
are saying now you came up with this
plan of playing King G 2 - King H 3 and
trying to invade along the H file and
that in fact is going to be the correct
plan here the point was the move that
you guys were mostly avoiding I think a
lot of you were avoiding it because I
paused in this position and so it's
probably not the natural recapture the
move to avoid is actually going to be G
takes h4 here this was car pops big idea
and trying to win this end game you play
the move G takes age for all of a sudden
this age Foursquare is permanently taken
away from your King and so as such it's
going to be very very difficult now to
invade with the King to come up with a
winning plan because this square is
blocked this square is blocked this
these squares are blocked there's
absolutely no invading on the Queen side
and so that leaves the f5 Square that's
the only square kind of in this big mega
fortress here that is left open for
white to try to invade through and quite
simply it's it's not going to happen you
know black will just pass for all of
eternity as soon as you try to come in
here while the Move King e6 is it's
perfectly fine and this the square is is
not going to fall to your hands black
will pass and pass and pass to his
heart's content
and there's not much you can really
achieve here you can even perhaps try
and go for it something like this but
once again if your knight can land there
that's well and good but your king is
never going to invade and so you're not
going to win this endgame so that is the
big reason why Karpov does not take on
h4 here as for the specifics King G 2 2
H 3 is not so bad but Karpov actually
found a better way to reorganize the
pieces instead on e3 is good but gosh
wouldn't it be better on f4 where it
guards all of these wonderful juicy
juicy squares and makes life very
difficult for black so rather than king
g2 and then taking on g3 as such he
plays this move Knight g2 and this move
is just a little bit slightly better
spends a little bit less time to get
what he wanted to achieve here
so some of you I know did say night g2
but I just wanted to introduce to you
guys this idea of not taking on H for
this move Knight g2 is actually where
this end game is famous because it's not
an intuitive move at all but it is the
move that car puffs played and it's very
logical right to win this game you need
to be able to invade with the king and
so Karpov leaves his options open on
this h-file
at the cost of the pawn for the moment
in order to give himself winning chances
here
Kasparov responded with H takes g3 King
takes g3 now and now King e6 okay so
King e6 has an obvious downside that
Kasparov didn't miss but Kasparov chose
to go for anyways so of course what's
the best move here well it's gonna be
the move that Karpov prepped with the
move Knight g2 he wants Knight f4 check
trying to drive this King away and
attacking both pawns at the same time
now Kasparov plays this move King f5 and
now I wanted to ask you which pawn
should you take which pawn should you
take here this is a very very important
decision which pawn to take who won in
84 85 gosh you're really calling them my
my chess history here I I think this is
the one that they just like gave up on
they just gave up on this thing cuz
nobody was winning chess games is that
true I don't know Karpov won nevermind
Karpov one you caught me they didn't
give up on this one that was a different
one D 5 D 5 H pawn H 5 H 5 D D 5 Center
D Phi passed pawn D 5 D 5055 the H pawn
intuitively question mark is it
intuitive if you have to ask yourself I
wonder take Harry h5 d 5 H pawn
otherwise black King invades not sure if
that's true not sure if the black King
invades if you take the D pawn
so the idea is very very very deep here
and well some of you may guess the
correct move in some of you may have
very logical reasons to find the correct
move it's honestly just like so far
above my head and I will be so impressed
if you guys actually get it so in fact
here you should take the edge pawn the
aged pawn is the pawn that you want to
take and I'm going to explain why you
shouldn't take the D pawn later on in
this game because it's going to be a lot
more obvious later later on but let's
say if we take on d5 this King doesn't
really get to invade any special way the
move h4 doesn't really do anything
because this pawn this night does defend
f4 square for the moment and so quite
simply black would would have to you
know pass a little bit with something
like Bishop d3 and then you can play a
move like 93 check King e6 and King h4
and you get a lot of the same stuff that
you would have otherwise but instead
Karpov
takes this H pawn instead now if we look
at a very very similar line to what
happened what would have happened if
Knight takes d5 we start to see kind of
a key difference here in the variations
so if we took on d5 in black played King
e6 we give this check King d6 and Knight
takes h5 all of a sudden black it gets
to come forward a little bit and take on
d4 now this specific line I think is
losing for black but black can do things
a little bit more cleverly by passing
for a little bit what's something like
Bishop d3 and if we start coming this
way we see this guy drop off the board
wait a second wait a second I can do
better I can do better that came back to
e6 King up to h5 takes King up to g6 and
now all of a sudden life is not so bad
for a for black after all and the reason
for this is by not having this pawn on
d5 it's true that we invaded with our
King but black is the one who has
counter chances now black is also
threatening to invade because this pawn
isn't on d5 so blacks counter play comes
through so much faster without this pawn
on the
this is one of those cases where black
is actually quite happy that you took
his d5 pawn off the board because it
gives them this ability to kind of fight
back here in the center rather than just
allow white all this free play
so Karpov being the mastermind that he
is leaves the d5 pawn on the board for
this reason this pawn just ends up being
in blacks way and that's what allows
white to try and win this endgame this
idea of leaving the pawn on the board to
her stick restrict the black King King
e6 was played in the game now Knight f4
check King d6
King g4 bishop c2 king h5 and the best
way of defending before black is what
Kasparov found this King invading over
here does leave this f3 pawn behind so
Kasparov takes the time out of his day
to come pick up this pawn King e7 first
and now Knight takes d5 comes on the
board and here believe it or not
Kasparov might have had a chance to try
and draw so I wanted to ask you guys if
you could find the best move here for
White Knight takes d5 potentially
actually going to be a small and
accuracy by Karpov here so see if you
can find the best move for white and
I'll give you a hint I've already
explained to you some ideas that could
lead you to find this best move here
and explain some ideas that can help you
out in finding the best move here
83-93 king of five going after a pawn so
night 65 the idea is very much to go
after this a pawn and we'll see
something like this happens in the game
but that is not going to be the winning
the best idea here for for white so
someone in the chat does have it a
couple people in the chat do have it and
the fact is the same question that I
asked you guys here as to which pawn you
should take and why you should you
shouldn't take the deep on this actually
does apply later in the game right here
in fact white is better off leaving this
D pawn on the board because it restricts
the black King so the main thing we want
to do with 95 is get rid of this f6 pawn
right so the best way to do it is
actually to play Knight h5 not capturing
this pawn on d5 as counterintuitive as
this looks now after move like Bishop
takes f3
we have Knight takes on f6 Bishop g4
King g5 and let's say it black just
passes for the rest of the game here in
fact well actually pass like this to try
it and keep this King out now the good
news for white is that this position is
going to be a lot easier to win now that
we've already taken off the f6 pawn now
we are kind of in the clear to take off
the d5 pawn and after move like Knight
c3 it's a lot easier to try and win in
this position I think although wait a
second I'm confusing my notes again okay
maybe we don't take on d5 just yet but
if we do do some clever rerouting like
this for example King e6 and all of a
sudden 95 there should be 4 knight c6
and we can go after this a pawn once
again leaving this d5 pawn on the board
so that the black King cannot get active
this is the idea kind of for white
leaving d5 on the board so the black
King cannot activate through the d5
square and it turns out this was
actually the best way to play in the
game
Karpov chooses Knight takes d5 instead
the downside being this King now does
have access
to the d5 square but fortunately for him
it did work out kini 6 was played 97
check and now the move King d7 it turns
out king d6 was actually the one that
was called for here and the reason for
that is you know not not so obviously a
parent at first but let's see what
happens after King b7 maybe it'll show
us the answer as to why King d6 is
better now simply Knight takes a 6 but
should takes f3 King takes f6 and the
King comes to d6 anyways and d6 just
being a better square trying to get this
King active but the fact is here it's
just a little bit too late if we compare
the same line after king d6 and it takes
a 6 game takes f3 king takes f6 in this
case things are ever so slightly
different because with this King already
on d6 we stop this King coming from a5
and we can now play this move King d5
check take Knight takes b5 and come over
and with our King so close to these
pawns this one is actually just going to
be a drill you can draw any way you like
fact is bishops going to sacrifice
himself for the final pawn so this key
moment here King d7 versus King d6 turns
out king d6 was the one was the one that
Kasparov needed likely he was worried
about the move 98 when after King d5 you
do lose to the move Knight takes f6 with
the past pawn but after 98 the funny
move King East 7 is the way to go when
after takes in takes black is actually
holding on in this position as well so
the key reason Karpov couldn't take off
this d5 pawn is because that allows the
black King to get active instead though
he kind of fell for it Kasparov though
plays King d7 not taking his chance to
draw the game now Knight takes a6 Bishop
takes f3 King takes f6 and this one is
going to be technically winning for
Karpov king d6 gets played still going
after this d5 square now King f5 King d5
and King f4 is just barely in time for
Karpov taking advantage of the
unfortunate placement of this Bishop and
now after Bishop h1 we have
King III and Karpov manages to guard
this pawn just in time
King c4 now Knights c5 I should see 693
95 check just a little bit of funny
maneuvering here note that if you do
come to b3 the problem is going to be
and that you get boxed out here on this
a file and with the King boxed out now
white is simply going to be winning if
you start passing I will one step at a
time
escort this pawn up the board with my
knight so can't go that way
which is why in the game 95 King c3 was
played avoiding getting boxed out now
knight c6 King c4 Knight 7 trying to
guard the square this should be 7 trying
to pass but now Knight f5 is unfortunate
for black Bishop back to g2 now Knight
d6 check King b3 no he takes b5 and
three pounds is enough King a 496 and
Kasparov threw in the towel here and
resigned so this is one of the most
famous and games of all time a lot of
really fun stuff to look at here really
really complicated stuff let's go
through it one more time at these two
key moments I really wanted to highlight
this moment right here is one of the
craziest kind of endgame moments in all
of chess that I think of a period at
such a high level the fact that night h5
is a better move and then taking the
free pawn on d5 with check is kind of
mind-boggling here but the idea is quite
simple you just don't want to allow this
King to get active to get to this d5
square instead though we saw a little
bit of an accurate play from both of
these players totally understandable in
this crazy endgame and Karpov did end up
winning also a key moment this moment
right here with Knight g2 Knight G to
the killer move by Karpov knowing that
in order to win the game he needs this
winning plan of invading with the king
and to do that we need access to this
age Foursquare really instructive stuff
so once again the point of this lecture
to win these end games you need to find
a winning plan to find a winning plan
you need to
with the king and so you need to allow
yourself and that kind of opportunity
all right we have a little bit of time
left here so I am going to treat you
guys to one more this time let's take a
look let's see what do I want here what
do I want here let's go with the pure
Bishop versus Knight once again here
here we have a game between Boris
Spassky and the one and only Robert
James Fisher this was a game played in
Santa Monica in 1966
excuse me sorry
and this is one that we have with
another night versus Bishop so this one
is a lot less obvious to to see who is
better if anybody is at all and
practically who has the winning chances
so I ask you guys at home to try and
come up with a winning plan for really
either side here or if you can't find a
winning plan and you think it's just a
simple draw that's that's also a fair
answer to the question so what do you
guys think about this end game here
whose move is it I'm sorry it is black
to move black to move important
distinction and you know what since
we're looking from the white side Knight
c4 was played in the game doesn't really
change the evaluation in the position so
Knight c4 played by Robert James Fisher
your name is Boris Spassky you have to
figure out who is better if there are
any winning plans in position for either
player apologies apologies bishop d5
dominate the knight would have been good
if it was White's turn but now Bishop d5
much worse now the black has gotten able
to been able to play move
put the bishop on d5 and push the
kingside pons is the plan for white yes
Bradley you are now boris spassky best
of luck to you
kini - okay these are not not winning
plans I'm looking for a more general
idea here
I liked the answer that said push the
pawns on the kingside that that's an
idea that's the general idea it's the
way to answer this question any other
plans
any other ideas central king for white
take advantage that the bishop plays on
both sides
John Joe Walsh says blacks hopes are on
his past seep on white is trying to
block it and make a passed pawn on the
kingside with the majority so you guys
have a lot of good ideas here so a lot
of you pointed out that white has this
kingside majority with these pawns on g4
and h5 you also pointed out the black
has this past see pawn kind of in return
for it there were there was one really
great statement that was made and kind
of as an afterthought I think in one of
these chat messages and that is the fact
the bishop is a long-range piece and so
you should try it and take advantage of
this and that's going to be the key to
this endgame a boris is going to try to
use this Bishop - yes work with his King
side pawns make a passed pawn on the
Kings side and use that to try to win
the game but he's also going to use this
Bishop to influence the Queen side at
the same time as well and this is the
inherent advantage of the bishop over
the knight the bishop is a long-range
piece can influence both sides of the
board at the same time and that's
something that the knight simply lacks
Knights also notoriously bad at stopping
passed pawns particularly rook pawns as
we noticed in one of those first
examples here so it is in fact going to
be white in this position that has all
of the winning chances because the
bishop is simply better than the knight
in this case the bishop very calmly
stops this sea pond by controlling the
c2 square or even the c-4 square if need
be
in the meantime likes going to have a
slightly harder time dealing with these
pawns on the Kings side that being said
the objective evaluation of this
position may actually just be a draw in
fact I very much think it is just an
objective draw here but that's less
important than who has the practical
winning chances and in this case it is
going to be white with the practical
winning chances because of this bishop
because this bishop can influence both
sides of the board so let's see what
Spassky does to try and make use of this
bishop against Bobby Fischer here so
King u2 was the first move played in the
game like someone said you want to
centralize your King 95 now King up to
e3
King up to e65 sixes played King a four
night back to f7 so Bobby it brings this
night all the way back here and tries to
influence the Kings side of the board
just a little bit Spassky play it King
III which is offering perhaps a one move
repetition with the move Knight e5 of
course he probably wouldn't go for more
than the one move and then Bobby it's a
little bit anxious plays the move g5 so
of course how should white respond to
this you don't want to trade pawns when
you're trying to win
so here white should play the move h5
and in fact now white is going to be
significantly better after the things
that kind of just took place I will
briefly mention the best kind of plan
for Bobby to just equalized was going to
be to play King h6 here which is a
pretty counterintuitive move you can
kind of continue by bringing this King
up the board
I met with this and then here after King
h6 you can play this move g5 and this is
kind of the drawing try for black you
get rid of this H pawn or force force a
trade of the Jeep on for the Aged pawn
white could play g3 but simply takes an
h4 should likely be good enough for
black and with this extra pawn off the
board it's much much easier to try and
draw this with black in fact King h5
might immediately already be picking up
this pawn so this was the equalizing try
but after a few moves we see g5 now h5
is possible with this King on f6 instead
and now Bobby is kind of in for a long
defensive struggle here now at age six
played in the game and now after Knight
age six white is quite simply totally
totally winning
none of a lot of time left in the
lecture so I'm just gonna show you guys
how Spassky did it
King d3 was played in the game King e5
for black and now Bishop a8 Bishop a
long range piece you want to get it out
of the way of this black King making any
threats so all the way on a eight it
gets tucked away and now we see how
strong this Bishop really is its
guarding all of these important squares
against black in fact it's also guarding
this g2 pond
gets any funny ideas tries to go this
way it's something like King G for next
thing you know this Bishop comes back in
a flash
and immediately challenges this Kings
try over here
and well you may eventually end up
winning and this pawn here on h5 you've
committed a little bit too hard to this
side of the board and now this a pawn is
going to run so just some ideas there so
Bishop a black tried King d6 trying to
defend King c4g for now and a4 a5 is
nice bye-bye white note black is just
relegated to passing at this point with
this King stuck to the C pawn this
Knight stuck to this H pond now Bishop
a4 we see g3 putting the pawn on the
dark square now King b5 9 g8 Bishop back
to b1 switching diagonals now aged 6 and
now King a6 and after king c6 Bishop a2
is a nice nice move by white here not
taking this pawn in the a7 just yet
making sure his pieces are placed
perfectly with bishop on c4 and here I
believe Bobby Fischer resigned
King takes a7 is unstoppable and now the
King does not even get to invade shows
you the power of the long-range Bishop
turning what seemingly is a pretty equal
position into a1 endgame almost like
magic alright hopefully you guys enjoyed
this endgame lecture that's gonna be it
for me here on the YouTube channel
tonight if you are watching live be sure
to head over to the twitch channel where
I will be analyzing some viewer games in
the class analyze your games if you're
watching the video thank you very much
for joining me tonight
I had a blast showing you this end game
these end games hopefully you learned
something once again my name is Caleb
Denby and I will see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you